ich habe gerade mal geguckt und zwar
müsste das einen es fünf sein kostet neu
230 euro und ich frage mich wieso wir
das nicht verkauft wie so liebten oben
auf dem dachboden den handy ähnelt was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen ja ich habe natürlich geht
es gut mir auch das ist nur wieder
extrem heiß aber das kennen wir ja schon
irgendwie habe ich gerade das gefühl
dieses shirt ist größer geworden seitdem
ich jetzt das letzte mal an hatte
natürlich erst mal anders ist das muss
so setz dich mal produziert und ist
ziemlich gutes licht um dann über all
die rollen konnte weil die sonne sonst
rein parat ich habe mir für heute was
sehr interessantes überlegt ich hatte
die idee sommer habe ich aber nicht
umgesetzt weil ich mir dachte eigentlich
ist das ja nur für mich selber
interessant jetzt habe ich aber vor
einer woche das video rausgehauen wenn
ihr es noch nicht gesehen haben schon
sich auf jeden fall an wo ich halt so
ein koffer ersteigert habe denn
irgendwer verloren hat und die sachen
daraus gezeigt habe so hier haben wir
den koffer ist einen handgepäcks kopf
das sind so strand seien daher also ich
kann mir vorstellen dass es hier
zigaretten
oh es ist natürlich auch nicht das ist
wirklich sehr gut angekommen und viel
angeschrieben alex macht wird nun
offenbar des vorlebens neue optionen
sind natürlich auch nicht immer also vor
allem im raum köln ist glaube ich hier
nicht sie irgendwie immer wirst jetzt
wir haben ja schon august allerdings
habe ich 60 kilometer von dort wo ich
wohne ich ja schon wieder viel zu lange
aber da müsste jetzt muss mal durch wir
morgen früh so was von der deutschen
bahn gefunden da kommen halt sachen von
der deutschen mal die epo gefunden
wurden unter den hammer alte werden da
versteigert er wollte ich morgen früh
vielleicht hinfahren und mal gucken was
ist da so wird weil ich hab halt ferien
trotzdem gibt es heute ein video unserem
dachboden so was kennen wahrscheinlich
die meisten von euch wir haben auch so
ein ding und dann macht man hier die
treppe runter es hat die richter
bestimmt
wieso wird alex auf dem dachboden hier
ist auch ganz schön warm weil das ist
direkt unterm dach jetzt hängt hier auch
jede menge wäsche war das fast voll gut
genau unter der woche her war wir haben
hier bestimmt 32 grad oben weil die
sonne natürlich auch das dach knallt
trotzdem wollte ich heute gerne ein
video raus und für euch und da das video
so gut angekommen ist wo ich halt ein
prägendes ausgepackt habe aus dem koffer
habe ich mir gedacht es könnte auch
interessant sein wenn ich einfach mal
dinge von mir früher hier suche weil ich
wohne jetzt schon über einem jahr in
köln bin aber natürlich hier groß
geworden und auf dem dachboden haben wir
extrem viele sachen verstaut von früher
von mir unter anderem und ich bin mir
sicher ich welche sachen finden
schon zehn jahren niemand mehr gesehen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht bevor ich
das alleine mache mache ich ein video
dazu vielleicht finden wir auch was cool
ist was man noch gut gebrauchen kann wie
zum beispiel ein computerbildschirm und
ich will gar nicht lange lagern die
wäsche ignorieren wir heute machen ich
kann euch gerne an kurzen überblick
geben wir haben hier schon mal extrem
viele spiele und so von mir früher mein
radio ja früher hatte jeder in seinem
kinderzimmer eigentlich so ein radio die
sind mehr sachen mit denen habe ich
nichts zu tun aber hier kommen ganz
viele kartons die eigentlich alle von
mir sind hier müssten auch noch sachen
von mir drin sein in dem schrank sowieso
und hier hinten playstation ich sehe
schon jesus also das ist hier oben
eigentlich so eine schatzkammer mit ganz
viel wäsche ich würde sagen ich stelle
die kamera erst mal hin und mache mich
auf die suche bis sofort ich würde
eigentlich echt am liebsten mein t shirt
ausziehen also was sich erstmals sagen
kann wir haben ja schon mal einen alten
bildschirm der bestimmt noch 30 euro
wert ist das haben ein allererster
computerbildschirm von lg müsste aber
bestimmt schon zehn jahre alt sein denn
lege ich auch mal schön hier hin
wir sind super viele gesellschaftsspiele
die habe ich allerdings immer gehasst
deswegen zeigt jetzt auch nicht dass ihr
lag auch in der ecke das ist so eine art
ja machen also
wo ich jetzt aber wirklich sagen muss
das hat schon eigentlich auch für mich
ein krassen werd ich habe einfach meine
carrerabahn wiedergefunden von keine
ahnung wie habe ich so mit acht jahren
bekommen auch wirklich eine gute von
skull ex trick falls man das so richtig
ausspricht hier ist noch komplett
vollständig mit allen teilt und die
autos müssten auch noch irgendwo
rumfliegen ich und ich habe davon nicht
nur eine sondern gleich zwei die konnte
man miteinander verbinden hatte man eine
größere da habe ich auch sehr gerne
mitgespielt vielleicht findet sich ja
irgendein sammler der die gerne haben
würde weil ich bin mir eigentlich
ziemlich sicher dass es diese modelle
gar nicht mehr gibt
heute kommt auch mit ich habe einfach
ich hab damit so gerne gespielt eine
ganze beyblade bahn gefunden
am main hofer bord das war die
verpackung von meinem hobart das habe
ich vor ungefähr drei jahren gekauft
aber das ist geil wir haben ja einfach
eine ganze beyblade sammlung mal gucken
ob das noch funktioniert
guy leise das tägliche sache habe ich
total vergessen dass ich wirklich
bestimmt zwei drei jahre meines lebens
mit blades verbracht haben okay ich
nehme euch jetzt einfach mal mit nach
hinten ich kann natürlich auch nicht
alle kartons durchforsten weil schaut
euch mal an wie viele das sind da kann
überall noch was cooles prinz endlich
wenigstens nicht gelöster form gerade
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr aber wenn
ihr sagt finde ich cool das ist auf
jeden fall mal daumen nach oben da oder
schreibt ein kommentar machen noch ein
paar aber wir sind ja noch gar nicht am
ende also eigentlich erst am anfang
weiter geht es hier drin sind so tiere
und so ein auto ich habe gerade einfach
so ein glas gefunden mit steinen
oh mein gott ich weiß es nicht das wird
sich jetzt unfassbar dumm an aber ich
habe früher immer steine angemalt um sie
dann zu verkaufen weil ein roter stein
ist ja was besonderes oder ein blauer
stein oder ein gelber steigen aber wieso
das hier oben steht wird sich auch gern
an das ding kann ich mich überhaupt
nicht mehr
wir haben hier in der ecke star wars da
was ist das denn
ok es staubt es ein bisschen leute und
hier haben wir die autos von der
carrerabahn bin ich mir auch wirklich
sehr sehr sicher dass man die nicht mehr
kaufen kann jetzt irgendwie ein
schmuckstück auch welt schreibt es mir
auf jeden fall wobei ich mir auch nicht
sicher bin ob ich davon eins verkaufen
würde das war mein lieblingsauto was
leute wir haben eine menge bücher und
wir haben dann samsung
geht leider nicht an also liegt
wahrscheinlich auch schon ein bisschen
also ich hatte meine samsung es vier
mini das war mein zweites handy das ist
allerdings ein aktuelleres das lustige
ist ich glaube das haben wir schon mal
gesucht ich hab grad mal geguckt und
zwar müsste das dann es fünf sein kostet
neu 230 euro und ich frage mich wieso
wir das nicht verkauft haben mir läuft
der schweiß runter weil ich bin mir
sicher das ist jetzt bestimmt schon über
ein jahr weg und von mir ist es auf
keinen fall
wieso legten oben auf dem dachboden
handy s5 von samsung s5230 haben wir die
sie kartons sie sind allerdings noch
nicht so als würde man sagen maximal 12
jahre eine ritterburg
wir haben wir nur so verkleidungs zeugs
das kenne ich eigentlich oder keinen
bock das jetzt hört zu wühlen nike air
force momenten walter h wieso ist hier
ein gewehr ich habe gerade einfach also
keine angst ist natürlich kein echtes
das hatte ich früher im kindergarten und
zwar bin ich als callboy gegangen und
dann braucht man natürlich auch ein
geiles gehört ihr könnt euch nicht ihr
könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie ich am
schwitzen bin ich habe gerade noch ich
glaube das hat meine mutter meine hin
räumt zitat für alle lebenslagen für
alex wie von marissa und berliner und
eine laptoptasche und das ist das hier
locker laser war das ist alles so zu
gestalten gewissen schwierig ich bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt schauen wir mal rein
wenn du glücklich bist traurig sein ist
eine verschwendung derzeit umfasst jetzt
aber irgendwann nicht jeder mensch
sollte einen smoking tragen außer am
sonntag da entspannt man sich also ich
glaube irgendwann vielleicht was
durcheinander gebracht
ich mache trotzdem lange für dieses
geschenk tja leute ist es wirklich
schwierig sich jetzt hier dran zu machen
da müsste ich alles
bücher dass der hbw schnee ansicht von
mir preis schaut euch das mal an ich war
auch mal so groß da habe ich
wahrscheinlich reingepasst und habe
immer vielleicht sich im schnee gespielt
den habe ich garantiert schon über 15
jahre nicht mehr gesehen da haben wir
noch so eine coole dampfwalze aber ich
habe ja gerade eben schon gesagt ja noch
ein paar schreibt es einfach in die
kommentare oder lasten daumen nach oben
da ich würd mal sagen bei 8000 likes da
dann kommt mein papa gerade wieder mit
dem fahrrad
hey ich muss hier unterstützt so warm
nicht dass ich hier noch kollabiere
ersten schluck wasser wasser ist ganz
wichtig wer dem wetter und das handy
nehme ich natürlich mit na ist sogar
gold von hinten schaut euch mal an das
sieht wirklich aus wie neu wenn irgend
wer interesse hat an ms 5 ich hatte ein
paar installiert da hässlich alex wie
beim schwitzen die leute dann würde ich
sagen ich habe mich jetzt an ein stück
vom video ich hoffe natürlich dass hat
euch gefallen lassen nur noch oben darf
als das der fall ist hier ist es
wenigstens wieder ein bisschen kühler
dann auf jeden fall gespannt auf das
morgige video war vielleicht wird cool
vielleicht kommt auch geeignet wenn es
nicht cool wir komplett videos
eigentlich jetzt immer so gegen abend
rechnen 19.20 uhr nächster zeit und ja
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns frau 36
auf jeden fall station instagram ab und
hier ist noch mal dass samsung dessen
identität ich gleich erstmal klären muss
hier ist übrigens das radio was ich eben
am anfang gezeigt habe ja geil sogar mit
antenne
willkommen im 19 jahrhundert